>> Tucker: WE JUST HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH PAMELA
ANDERSON ABOUT JULIAN ASSANGE
AND VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THEN UBER AND LYFT IS POPULAR
WITH THE PUBLIC.
SHE IS CAMPAIGNING AGAINST RIDE
SHARING APPS.
LURING DRIVERS AND EXPLOITING
THEM.
TELL US WHAT YOU MEAN?
>> EVERYBODY KNOWS THE
DIFFICULTIES THEY ARE OCCURRING.
PEOPLE ARE BEING SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED.
THE DRIVERS ARE EXPLOITED.
THEY ARE HIRED AS 3rd-PARTY
PROVIDERS.
UBER IS NOT TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ANY OF THEIR
WRONG DOINGS.
ALSO THEY ARE NOT GETTING HEALTH
CARE OR ANY OF THE THINGS THEY
SHOULD BE RECEIVING AS
EMPLOYEES.
>> Tucker: I AM CONFUSED.
THE PEOPLE WHO RUN UBER ARE
SOCIALLY CONSCIOUS AND GOOD
PEOPLE.
THEY SAY THEY ARE VERY GOOD
PEOPLE AND RICH.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY PAY FOR THEIR
HEALTH CARE FOR THE DRIVERS?
>> EXACTLY.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE FACT FOR.
ALSO YOU WILL GET BETTER EQUAL
DRIVERS.
MORE QUALIFIED DRIVERS.
WHEN PEOPLE HAVE REAL BENEFITS
AND MINIMUM WAGE.
>> Tucker: I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY NOBODY SAYS ANYTHING ABOUT
THIS.
IF A FACTORY WERE PAYING PEOPLE
WHAT UBER PAYS PER HOUR AND NOT
PAYING FOR THEIR HEALTH CARE --
WELL, WAL-MART DID IT.
PEOPLE SAID THIS WAS
EXPLOITATION BUT UBER GETS A
PASS.
WHY?
>> IT'S TECHNOLOGY AND
EVOLUTION.
WE HAVE TO RIGHT THE WRONGS.
I SAY IF YOU ARE A SEXUAL
OFFENDER, YOU SHOULD GET A JOB
AT UBER.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE NOT FOR UBER?
>> NO.
I AM NOT FOR THESE RIDE HAIL
APPS.
YOU ARE SENDING STRANGERS TO
PICK UP CHILDREN OR A LATE NIGHT
OUT AND DRINKING TOO MUCH.
IT'S AN AP, PEOPLE THINK IT'S
SAFE.
IT IS NOT SAFE.
IT HAS BUGS TO WORK OUT AND THEY
NEED PROPER PAYMENT TO THE
DRIVERS.
ANYBODY CAN BE AN UBER DRIVER.
THEY HAVE TO FINE-TUNE THAT.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU SAYING THE
BILLIONAIRES WHO RUN UBER ARE SO
GREEDY, THEY WON'T TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES?
>> I THINK PEOPLE ARE FINDING
ALL OF THESE LOOP HOLES.
THEY HAVE TO TIGHTEN IT UP.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE AFFECTED
LIKE THIS.
THE EMPLOYEES AND THE DRIVER.
THE DRIVERS ARE THE CORE OF THE